Peck us to death if chickens were the
size of a Velociraptor they do you know
chickens eat rats they they Peck they're
not they're not [__] omnivores like
they tell us YouTube Chicken eating rat
it chases mice and rats pecks them to
death and eats them they're not
herbivores they're lying to us oh
chickens if chickens were the size of
cat ly cat a ly man's best friend who's
Man's Best Friend dog dogs are rapists
dogs hump you without consent they bite
you without consent they would eat you
if they could well no no thinking
animals are the good guys is the dumbest
[__] humans of ever done when someone
dies DMT and the cops show up and the
ambulance show up if that person owned a
dog the dog is chilling next to the
person waiting starving they found
starving dogs next to their [__]
Masters right when they come that's an
autistic dog when they come to the house
and it's cats the person's face is
[__] shredded to bits they eat the
they eat all the [__] family but the
cats will not starve next to their
masters the dog will but dogs make men
little [__] Americans have dogs
Russians have cats Russians are more
hardcore CU cats teach you to to have an
independent mindset dogs teach you like
when does mommy come home it teaches you
how to be like a little home body a lot
of people got dogs during the co
pandemic who don't belong having dogs
when you see a lady put a [__] chest
protector on a pitbull and it's dragging
her down the street that person does not
belong having a dog right and a lot of
single women are replacing the alpha
male with a [__] Alpha pit right and
some of them are even well we don't have
to say single women just say dogs yeah
and some of them are even having sex
with those dogs what the [__] yeah okay
wa detour how did we get
here some of these single women with pit
bulls and and no I've SE I've seen
stories come out like that you be
surprised bro yeah show me a book on
female SE sexuality they would send
their fantasies to this author in the '
80s they anonymously and these women's
fantasies were about dogs children
watching knives being cut like female
sexuality is demonic when left unchecked
you buy into this it can be and this is
another we were talking earlier about
the teachers the rape fantasy 80% of
women have the r fantasy oh no so I had
um I had an only Fant guy on my show and
he told me that the number one thing he
gets requested from women is is rap
fantasy yeah yeah see that's crazy I
used to you know what I us what men need
to learn more than anything especially
these young college men is okay you're
good at getting a woman night one you
bring her back to your house next day
what happens buyers remorse then also
the woman says oh I was raped men need
to put in checks and balances a get
consent B you got to build up some type
of Rapport right you can't just go home
with a drunk chick sleep with her and be
like okay get out of my house oh by the
way these same dudes are telling their
whole Social Circle you're an idiot why
can't you just have sex with a girl keep
your mouth shut keep it to yourself Z
don't you tweet like every girl you look
up with yeah no I said I've seen you I
said to Zoomers if you hook up with a
woman and you do not do after care if
you don't cuddle them if you don't make
them feel special you're a rapist that
next morning 100% you're a rapist but
these guys will hook up with a girl and
then they'll be like you know I got to I
got to wake up for work you got to leave
my apartment are you can't just [__] her
until to leave what you zerka you can't
no you can't and you got to have some
form of consent right maybe it's a text
message something I think audio I just
record audio something wri any woman who
dates me I'm illegally audio recording
the whole day
right I'm kidding I'm a comedian depends
what well but yeah here's the thing
though here's the thing you said buyers
remorse if you're hooking up with a lot
of women but then they they ghost you
after what you're doing over time is
your confidence is going down cuz you
have a crush on her but now she blocked
you after [__] you cuz she found out
you're just some loser from the club mhm
it's even if you want to be a if your
goal is to be a player it's about
sustaining them if you're just [__] a
lot of women and they getting blocked by
the girls you have a crush on you're
becoming less confident over time you
have a horrible reputation in town
you're looking very creepy and now the
hotter girls in town won't mess with you
cuz you're messing with those girls
that's why I say for men Focus quality
over quantity and quantity is easy you
just I know a guy who has a fake
Instagram fake Lamborghini fake
everything's fake he doesn't live a rich
life and it works women actually sleep
with this guy cuz they think he's Rich
yeah and it's all fake fake all wi fake
everything and then what happens when
they find out he's not real well they
never find out these women are
[__] they actually they never find
out that's the scary Bo but yeah and
it's like do you want women getting with
you because you have a Lambo because
you're rich or do you want to actually
build real attraction first and be
someone who's cool oh that also comes
into being brutally honest sometimes
yeah if if you want women just cuz you
have a Lambo you're like I don't care
there's no genuine burning desire then
you're telling me You' [__] a corpse
right she has no desire to sleep with
you but you have a Lamborghini so you're
sleeping with her that's like if she was
dead you would have sex with there a
dead body has no desire to sleep with
you it's dead it's creepy that you want
to just get the woman through some
material right and then this comes back
to the family combo right where you see
Will Smith's not immune you could have
richness you could have Fame you could
have the lambo if you're whack at the
end of the day you're still whack and
the woman's going to lose attraction for
you right and then you hear dudes I
can't believe she cheated or I can't
believe I got divorced I can believe it
when they tell me I can't believe she
cheated I go I in my head for most of my
friends will get cheated on I'm like I
told you a year ago she would cheat I'll
tell you the caveat though the one
caveat is like I I think of Angelina
Jolie do you remember her first husband
Bobby Billy Bob she you could tell she
had genuine desire she had really
attracted to him and what did people say
how how Billy Bob how did he get no no
but I'm saying like until wait yeah
exactly until she met Brad and then she
got Alpha widow she got Alpha Widow and
Bad Brad was like because like and I've
just noticed this trend like if women
are around too too many and this was
even in like like hundreds of years ago
like the the high like the rich women
would cheat because they're just around
too many high status men I always tell
people like if your girl is not poor she
will leave you like you have to find a a
poor woman you can't find like have you
ever dated a rich girl she thinks that's
what Le's all about like she came from a
rich family so she expects you to have a
Rolls-Royce and stuff that's a broken
mindset go man you know how happy I hate
passport Bros cuz they're cringe they go
to Japan but you know how happy American
men would be if they just got married in
Colombia to some poor woman it's
perspective and people are like I'm
going to bring her here no no cuz you
don't want to bring your Colombian here
around us you want to stay there you
don't want to they're like I'm going to
bring a hot Colombian around zurka in
America no cuz they immediately start
switching up they go okay you now that I
have the Visa I can meet zurka if you
have your hot Colombian stay in that pig
form but then how many times will the
foreigners come here then they catch the
progressive virus right it's only a
matter of time before the progressive
virus spills in these women start to
look the grass is greener on the other
side or some say they get it through
Instagram in their home country that's
the that's the point Guys these other
countries are just 20 years behind we we
like no but like said they're even
getting it in other countries Instagram
they're getting blue pill correct yeah
because um just being in London we
interview girls like literally from
Eastern Europe from Asia like from
everywhere yeah it's coming and then we
interview I'd actually say more
blackpilling is the guys that come from
these countries where they're like
talking about the decline of the women
blessing being one yeah I I I used have
this game I used to tell my chat this
game I'm like you want to play a very
dangerous game to see if you're the man
spend one week stressed panicking with
your girlfriend telling her you lost
everything and watch in less than 5 to
seven days she is not your girl her DMS
are open she's looking for a way out
even if she stays with you a month if
you make a and no man will do this why
would I worry her for seven days I'm
like I still remember I had a girlfriend
uh my last girlfriend I said I lost
everything and I'm not allowed to go
live I have been off the platform I have
no money I need $1,000 I asked my girl
and I could not believe the girl who's
cutting her wrist for me in love with me
started acting like why do you need
money I'm like [__] you know how much
money I spent on you give me a th000
bucks it was like pulling [__] teeth
she she obviously wanted to give me the
money and stuff but in her head she's
thinking oh [__] this guy used me for my
vagina is poor and now the ship is
sinking right it could be the kindest
woman I I'm telling you I I want to sell
this advice no one would do it if you go
to your girlfriend or wife and just
start freaking out breaking glass in the
house and saying dude I lost I lost
everything I lost everything I I have to
I have no money and you start freaking
out you're going to see that love in her
eyes turns into fear you're not taking
care of me and I swear
breaking [__] check this out check this
out you know why no man will listen to
this advice they know deep down in their
hearts within seven days their wives
aren't who they think they are no one
would ever no man would risk this game
see because we do you remember when the
Cavs lost the 2017 NBA Finals yeah yeah
I lost like big sick figures a wife knew
about it she didn't leave me but she was
pissed but check it out here's the thing
too like okay I'm going to tell you I
lost everything but then on the same
breath am I telling you I'm about to get
it back and we're going to be all right
or am I saying [__] I need your help at
that point women are subconsciously
wired where [__] now I'm you're making
me the leader you're making me the
provider and the protector I feel scared
now and and here's now now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to run to the
next man who's not scared and people
think oh it's cuz a starvation thing and
stuff it's not if you go broke your
business goes under but you have 5
million in assets she still panics so
even if she still has a big house and a
car but your business is off you're no
longer the man she still panics even if
you have 10 million left over but you're
just chilling on the couch with 10
million she looks at you chilling on the
couch like you're not taking you're not
bringing more it's always more so people
think oh they're going to leave you cuz
she's going to think she's going to
starve you could say honey I have $10
million left but my business is done and
I'm going to play Playstation for the
rest of my life the 10 million is not
enough for her to be aroused she needs
you to always be working she needs to
always see a Workhorse how your mind
state is right and how you're like are
you panicking or are you still art of
the deal now hold on I got the money I
got the money the thousands but I kept
checking I'm like why what happened to
her arousal it went from here to here
and so I kept extracting money out of my
girlfriend and you know at the end I
reward ordered her I took her to a nice
resort when I was like I'm kidding at
the end of the week but I needed to
see I needed to see if my level of charm
girls try and kill themselves if I break
up with them I want to see if I'm
Invincible I'm not Invincible even even
I led her arousal somehow and this is a
great way to for guys who are stuck in
the friend zone right if start asking
the chick for favors yeah hey can I have
a ride here yeah give me money hey I'll
pay you back give me 500 I'll pay you
tomorrow start doing that a lot of dudes
get stuck in the friend zone because
they're constantly doing the favors and
jumping through hoops yeah right by the
way if she gives you money right away
and panics for you those ones you can
marry those ones IM in their head you
know what they're telling you you're
better than me you'll make your money
back but if she starts going what
happened to your money that one does not
think you guys are on the same level she
thinks she's better than you meaning
she'll cheat and this is also why women
get over men way quicker yeah because
because in ancient times Warlords would
come in Slaughter all the men and say
you're my new wife these women would be
smiling within a week and having sex
with the warlord and they teach us that
no he's raping her no go read history
these women were happy in a week they
forgot about their husbands well when a
man would go off to war or go on for a
hunt and never come back that was common
and what does a woman have to do at that
point a immediately find a new man to
protect and provide right so it's not
even their fault you can't change
thousands of years of wiring in one
generation right so a woman's
subconscious brain is still like wired
to immediately get over the man and go
on to the next protector and provider
you know it may not make sense in 2023
Society but the brains are still wired
that way this is why men are still
afraid to approach women in the street
and if you don't want to hate women just
think if if it's your daughter if zurka
said to your daughter hey I'm broke give
me money you tell your daughter did sh
that makes a lot of sense cuz I always
say like when a girl's over it like
she's like you're basically dead to her
like she's she's not I get emails all
the time saying zura she's done with it
as of the 10th I'm like no she was done
with it months before that you're you're
not we're not going back to the 10th to
see what you did wrong on the T when
she's done with you she was done months
in advance there's always signs before a
lot of guys can't read the signs or the
body language or the cues they're
they're always there months in ADV ADV
it's so simple to know if your woman
respects you or not when you enter the
house they actually do this oh John's
here but if they're like John's here
they don't respect you go look at any
girl who has a crush on you they get
tense when the CR even if they're happy
to see you they get tense when the crush
walks in but if they're in different
when you walk in you're so [__] I
remember my ex said I'm freak out every
time me walk in the room I feel like I'm
doing something wrong I I I can't talk
to you I'm so afraid of you I'm like
yeah exactly why you never cheat on me
you have to be afraid of me like I feel
like I'm always doing something wrong
John I'm like that's how you're supposed
to feel you're supposed to be on your
toes cuz if a woman is not investing in
you she's cheating they need to bro if a
woman likes you she does you favor she
does everything for you and then she
starts bragging she's like I'm like your
mom right but here's why it's worse to
lose a woman losing a woman is way worse
than losing a boyfriend let's say a
girlfriend because the man sees himself
as a father figure to her usually that's
why she stays with him it's like a
father archetype she feels safe oh my my
the first man I met kept me safe he has
to be like the first man so when he
breaks up with a girl when they break up
he is losing a daughter parents are not
meant to lose a child they're supposed
to go first the parents pass away the
child grows up women losing a father
they're used to that you know the father
grows old dies blah blah blah so it's
way more hardcore for the man during a
break up CU he's losing a daughter no
human can can can fathom losing
something younger than them but the
younger can fathom them losing something
older they lost their grandpa they lost
this they're just programmed to like get
over it quicker and that's where a lot
of guys mess up too where they'll look
at their wife or their girlfriend like
that they could talk to her like they
talk to their mother Yik like no one's
going to be your mom no one's going to
care about you as a man as a boy like
your mom did and when you start coming
to your wife or your girl with that Mom
[__] she's going to fall right out of
love with you I would see the live
streams I would see this girl I dated
she's all happy joyful bubbly around me
and I would watch our live streams at
the carnival I'm like wow she's so
feminine then I watched her with her
next guy why are we at the why are we at
the carnival why are we doing this are
you going to be streaming forever what
kind of job do you have she's so
aggressive to him I'm like because he
was not masculine she did not do
feminine and he allowed that yeah he
should have checked that a girl will
break all her rules for Drake a dude for
not even a drake cuz like or high status
some yeah or just someone who makes them
feel a certain type of way safe it's
always safe oh I'll never go to a
carnival with anyone then a few weeks
later she's out of Carnival cuz that
dude can have fun at a [__] grocery
store I'll never have sex with a guy the
first night but it's John zerka are you
[__] you know how many girls I've
seen never have sex the first night then
here I come and I go look at you Batman
breaking their one rule right like are
no R I feel like the Joker there are no
rules if you're the right guy man if
you're the right guy you can punch her
in the face and she'll sneak around no
no don't do it but I'm saying they bro
do you know how many okay Russia do you
know how many drug dealers I know that
beat up their girlfriends and the
girlfriends will NE never rat on them or
cheat and people say it's out of fear no
it's not it's a woman's psychologies
like this don't hit women they think if
my man beats me up he's aggressive no
burglar can come in here this guy's
psychotic he'll kill the burglar so they
they take it as the external world I'm
safe from that but sometimes I get
punched no that's part but if they're
around a s they cheat on the S and never
[__] laid a backand on her no you'll
see white like a white knight will try
to intervene if a dude's um you know
abusing on his girl in public for
example right okay that's a good
intention like we don't want to see a
woman getting beat but that woman's
going to go right back with that dude
and she might actually help her
boyfriend kill you for intervening yeah
you might go to jail because you try to
protect her from that guy obviously it's
a tough place to be in I don't think
simps should try and protect women cuz
they die simps literally die trying to
protect women it's not your role bro
right I think us we have to act and we
have a chance of winning you're over and
[__] her but yo down check it out
check it out women are evil but at 5
years old they find out that a few tears
and they can make their dad buy them
anything they learn deception bro when I
was five and I cried my dad's like why
are you crying like a [__] mhm but but
if a daughter cries my dad would have
been like oh my God honey let's get you
something men submit to women and Brar
as much as I want to say we don't need
women to be successful the books I'm
reading about sexual transmutation that
the will of the universe and all
horniness is why men build Bridges and
stuff apparently the greatest Geniuses
throughout history you were right he was
all inspired by some woman like that's
they would be around a certain but
there's also there's also zura zura
there's also Geniuses in history that
hid themselves from women oh yeah homos
right no no no they weren't even like
like there there are guys that I can't
remember who off the top of my head but
it was like they would get away from
their wives because they felt like they
couldn't be as creative with them around
or like as productive so there are guys
that would literally drains yeah they
would literally like hide from their I
mean think about it why did why is there
a man cave cuz they're trying to get
away when I hear that conversation it
might be different from my perspective
because like you know I'm more of like a
natural if I'm going to build a bridge
or like build this awesome thing I'm
never thinking that I'm doing it for a
woman ever I'm doing it because it's my
natural urge as a man to like build and
Conquer you know
what family no do you know what I no no
I'll tell you why I don't I don't
believe this no no no because I think if
women like disappeared tomorrow like we
wouldn't have room Buzz we wouldn't have
like any of these like small things like
decorations no do you know do you know
what I was thinking I was I was thinking
men would have explored the bottom of
the ocean by
now yeah like cuz think about it you
think any woman well I know there was
the one but in general women like that
tight submarine thing the Titan like you
know what I'm talking about that
imploded this year like that's such a
guy thing to do to want to explore like
the bottom of the ocean like the
distraction wouldn't be there I don't
know if because these books I'm reading
are really going against what I think
they're saying that men only go after
Legacy because of a woman in their head
and it's sometimes it's not their wife
sometimes it's like a woman they met
when they were teenag this is what I
this is what I think my belief I think
there's a natural order of the world I
think it goes God men women children and
when you do things for women then you're
putting women on a pedestal and it
messes up the natural order wait wait
would men work if women didn't exist
right now I think yeah I think they
would I don't think they would I think
it' be two weeks I no I what I think
would happen is they would do things
that like are naturally like like men
want to explore the world that's just
like a man thing to do um I don't think
they would I think in two weeks men
would stop no I don't think so well
think about it as a young boy right you
underestimate how horny men are would
men really after two weeks of no women
on earth stilling Z Zur I'm saying I'm
saying I'm saying they would do if I had
to guess I think they would do different
things like I think there are certain
men that pursue certain career paths for
women because they know it'll get them
women money status whatever I think if
women disappeared tomorrow you would see
men almost Return To Nature a little bit
more you'd see more guys being Farm you
see more yeah go ahead when we were boys
when I was a boy women girls had coties
right now it's herpes most most boys
girls have coties what were we doing as
boys though we were still building we
were still exploring we were still doing
all that you know that that was natural
for us instinctual to do you know so
that's a good argument I think a lot of
these guys who write these books about
like there's a woman they're doing it
for that's the type of man they are yeah
right well I and I think that goes with
the what you described comes from God
like I think that's like normal Med sub
submitting to God because I I think
that's like god-given men's like innate
like want to explore build that sort of
stuff yeah like before I ever was
attracted to female I was hitting home
runs I was drawing I was building things
in the backyard you know what I mean I I
loved the game so to speak I mean here's
the argument you guys should be making
every ventor genius Pythagoras Plato
they're all
homos like every one of them bid from
the fruit of knowledge well they're all
homos and they achieve the most without
women that's the argument you guys
should be making well when this comes
into blood flow and bandwidth and energy
utilization right if I'm uh Tesla and
Einstein if I'm lifting weights and
having sex with women what energy and
blood do I have left for my brain to
develop and establish and invent
not that's the book I just finished
yesterday show me a jacked inventor zero
that's the book I finished yesterday
about sexual transmutation it said all
inventors and Geniuses hit hit their PE
they actually pop off at 50 to 60 years
old when they stop chasing sex and that
Sexual Energy goes into their work but
before that apparently they're wasting
it on girlfriends and wives cuz they're
not even making families they're just
having yeah but that's that's why I
almost think like all of this women have
this Divine
energy I I just see it as like another
way to put women on a pedestal I just
see it as like women Market because I've
just noticed a trend that like whenever
you say bad things about women or
anything like negative if I say females
have [__] women are like the CEOs of
like their brands almost so they'll come
in and try to find a way to make it
better like like like for example I'll
say women are more likely to kill
infants and like they'll immediately say
well it's because the women are with the
kids more so they're trying to make it
into more of a positive thing right they
spin it but I was studying what was
before chemicals and chemistry it was
called Alchemy and what was Alchemy it
wasn't turning lead to Gold that's
philosophical lead is your brain turning
into a genius through semen retention
that if you could live a sainthood style
life if you could retain seen that
electricity that sexual drive after a
month or two you start having your
deepest strongest ideas and then Carl
Young would do this through it was
called um active imagination and type of
meditation as you retain semen yeah I
genuinely think you're not supposed to
Spill the seed imagine a fighter who
just come no that's not a fighter
imagine you're UFC fight and you just
ejaculate it then you have to go in
there are you as aggressive are you as
cerebral in there no we spoke about this
other day a little bit and this is where
Muhammad Ali actually messed up he did
it right but he said oh I'm not going to
have sex for three months before a fight
right sex isn't the issue it's spilling
the seed issue you can Edge so he would
have even been better off what is what
is Edge edging is like you're having sex
but you are not allowed to come so
you're You're Building electricity in
your body bio if if me and zurka are
going to fight right and I ejaculate
before the fight and he doesn't who's
going to have a better chance at winning
the fight it's not the Sleepy prolactin
shot up I'm going to want to go to sleep
but now if we're going to work out and
it's like okay if you just had sex
without ejaculating yeah now you're
pretty much turning the engine now who's
going to win that fight yeah that guy's
going to be way rapist he'll be like a
rapist in there exactly but then it's
not just spilling the seat it's
channeling that energy up the spine to
the brain back down to the navl and
circulating it through breath work and
this is what Freemason all these Gnostic
texts would talk about they what and I
it hit me I'm like why do why can women
have five orgasms cuz you're not
supposed to come they're not spilling a
seed this is also why women live longer
than men because women aren't spilling a
seed and when women do come or nut it
gets recycled into the uterus and have
you ever had sex and be like honey make
sure I don't come cuz I have a lot of
things to do today and then you get out
and you crush it but you're not people
think you're horny out there not really
you're electric you're not horn it's not
like you're thinking I have to go back
and ejaculate to my wife you're thinking
she's there she'll be there it's not a
simpy thing it's how you harness the
energy too a lot of guy and there's a
lot of dudes online who will say this is
[__] try it if you think it's
[__] try it once I I thought it was
[__] I tried it and then I'm like oh
my God my girlfriend I she would make
sure I don't come so I can be funny on
live stream well guess what else this is
this actually helps relationships right
because oxytocin the reason a dude
doesn't want to see the girl anymore is
because he just nutted that's a whole
oxytocin chemistry right where if I hold
that in now I want to hug her more now I
love you literally fall around the house
more and stuff like that if you come she
could be eating a piece of toast and you
want to punch her yeah you don't get
that same get away from me you don't get
that same get away from me and that's
why a lot of dudes need to practice this
and it'll help their relationship ay
you're going to satisfy your lover more
or here's the thing
do it your way it's clearly working what
these people in society